I finally got my absolutely beautiful
iPhone 15 Pro Max and I want to show you
guys the coolest set of accessories this
is the awesome new creators kit from ma
featuring their moas leather case with
this beautiful nice durable strong
texture as well as their wallet stand
that lets you prop it up with three
different angles you could watch videos
browse through Twitter or set it up in
standby mode and it looks absolutely
beautiful on the 15 Pro Max and you can
also mix and match the case with their
other three colors for the wallet so if
you're upgrading to any of the iPhone
15s you're going to want this set from
our sponsor mofft